canada does not actually have
the
uh
oil and gas infrastructures necessary to
replace
the significant share of european energy
that is received by russia received from
russia
we will of course
engage in conversations with our
european partners on how to make sure we
are
getting them off of
russian oil and gas
but also ultimately getting off the
dependence on oil and gas
entirely
canada can perhaps play a role in
facilitating that transition
off of oil and gas
and in the more immediate off of russian
oil and gas but those are significant
conversations that we are starting to
have with our partners about how to get
to hydrogen how to how to move forward
on renewables how to uh supplant in a
shorter term their reliance on on russia
canada has an extraordinarily um
extraordinary number of hard-working
people in our energy industry who are
both looking at conventional but also
renewables for the future and i know we
can be part of the long-term solution as
we as we move forward on uh mr bromwich
can you please clarify what this means
for
his subsidiary companies operations in
canada we know that they're a huge
contributor to pipeline manufacturing so
what happens are all those operations
now
seize completely and what about the 2200
people that are employed by them
first of all the sanctions on uh
russian officials and oligarchs like
abramovic are directed at them so that
they cannot profit or benefit
from economic activities in canada or
the hard work of canadians working in
companies that they have investments in
i believe abramovic
owns shares that are worth a little less
than 30 percent of uh evraz um
we are obviously going to watch
carefully but we are confident that this
will not impact the hard-working uh
canadians who uh are doing good work in
in companies across the country
including now so those operations
continue yes